was cressida dick right to go
well i think she was left with no choice
i think the way sadiq khan has dealt
with this is appalling
he should have spoken to her quietly as
opposed to dripping things to the media
putting her on notice etc that's no way
to treat
somebody that works for you or somebody
that's worked for the police service for
nearly 40 years i think it's a disgrace
um she she was really left with no
option i think
palm sandy left with no option would you
agree with that
i think it was actually time for her to
go and i think that the mayor sent out a
very clear message very strong message
that enough was enough
we've been having these catastrophes
month after month and there was no plan
to actually deal with them and he he
held the commissioner to account and
that's why this has happened and and i i
feel that was the right thing to do
just staying with you you say that there
was no plan to sort the situation out
and yet she did have a plan but the
mayor didn't like it
sarah everard has been dead nearly a
year now and the report that came out
last week with the chairing cross
officers
was done in 2018. those incidents
happened in 2017.
so you know that's four years later over
a year later
the two sisters that were photographed
and the images shared in a distressing
way
that was over a year ago so that plan
shouldn't have been in the offices last
week it should have already been
implemented so when i say that the
commissioner was being held to account
that plan should have already been
agreed implemented not be written in the
last week
yeah susan hall
just on that point do you think that
this void we now have at the top of the
met means uh there is going to be a real
problem as we face this critical point
in in the met's history
well it is a critical point which is i
go back to my original point to you i
think the way that sadiq khan has
handled this is appalling i don't deny
that there are clearly issues in the
metropolitan police there really are
nobody can deny that what i'm saying is
i think the way sadiq khan who is the
police and crime commissioner for london
uh policing is his responsibility in
london it's part of his responsibility
as mayor i think the way he's dealt with
this is appalling and i'm sure please
forgive me i've forgotten the lady's
name that's on at the same time i'm sure
she wouldn't have wanted to have been
treated in quite the way he has treated
her he um renewed her contract in just a
couple of months ago
um for another two years all these
things had happened before then so you
know if he really did care i'm amazed
that he didn't address these issues
earlier it's his responsibility as well
yeah it's palm sandu uh who we're we're
speaking to along with you susan and
just staying with you susan do you think
that the home secretary
and the mayor can actually work together
as they try and sort this mess out and
find a replacement or is there a danger
that policing is going to get very
political a bit like it is in in the
united states
well
politics has no place in policing
they have got to work together the
safety of londoners is the most
important thing
i don't think sadiq khan has kept london
and save it as i say as a police and
crime commissioner it's his
responsibility
he must work with their home secretary
and i'm sure she will work with him we
cannot be headless as it were the
metropolitan police it's not fair to all
those good officers that are there the
the problem with us all talking about
all these issues that have gone wrong
and there are if you think about it as
43 000 people work for the metropolitan
police
um
there are issues with a with some of
them a percentage but a very small
percentage and i feel so sorry for those
officers that go to work every day that
are brave that have worked hard and
they've got this hanging over them we
have to find a replacement for crested
dick as quickly as we can yeah palm
sandy you're nodding along there clearly
clearly
you're agreeing with susan on that point
i do agree with susan because the
majority of police officers are good
kind hard-working individuals and they
are there for the right reasons
but the problems that we're we're
talking about now it's not just one one
bad apple or one burden it's far more
than that and that's where the failings
over the last years have now come to
fruition and that that needs to be dealt
with but yeah i do agree with susan that
the majority of police officers are
there for the right reasons but i don't
agree that um the met is going to be
headless because the work will still
carry on you know all of the inquiries
all of the investigations will start to
still carry on the mayor the
commissioner will be there for another
few weeks and really there's no reason
why they can't find another replacement
and i do feel that it's quite um
i think it's a wrong thing to say that
there were no suitable replacements last
year there are 43 forces across the
country being led by very good chief
constables surely one of those could
have slotted in yeah let's look to the
future then um susan hall do you think
uh that this job actually is too big for
one person it needs to be split you've
got somebody who just looks after
policing in london and doesn't have to
do the counter-terrorism element as well
because that's a huge task
it is a huge task and actually we don't
praise that enough the counter-terrorism
is
phenomenal with the work that they do
for obvious reasons we don't get to hear
much about it but i can assure you it's
incredible work um there's so much that
the met does that is really really good
we only hear when things go wrong
and when they go catastrophically wrong
as they have done on a few occasions
problems completely right
um
then that will take media attention but
i do assure you the amount of work that
the police do that is really commendable
it should be out there far more i think
their comms is just dreadful i've said
so for a long long while the way they
communicate is
really bad yes sorry to interrupt and
and palm sandy do you think there's also
an argument uh for somebody without a
policing background to come and uh uh be
the met police commissioner someone who
knows about communications as susan hall
was saying that who knows about people
management
i'm not sure that is the answer because
at the moment you've got a police
officer who knows policing who knows
counter-terrorism and if you split the
jobs there will be duplication there'll
be other departments created and you
need that one person to have that
oversight communication has been an
issue um across the met and in recent
years but that can be addressed by
having a good team around you who deal
with those those certain points to make
sure that the public know what you're
doing and susan makes a good point not
everybody knows what police officers do
or how complex the work is and that's
where this has all fallen down it's all
very well for people to sit in their
offices and say we're going to do this
we're going to do that
but where's the consultation where's the
public involvement where's the
stakeholders the partners
you know i don't see any of that and how
many other members of the public
actually see that happening
yeah uh fascinating getting both of your
uh points of view thank you very much
palm sandy former chief superintendent
and also susan hall uh leader of the
conservatives on the london assembly
good to speak to you thank you